[Music]
the u.n estimates more than one and a
half million people have fled ukraine
since russia's invasion of that country
the european union says as many as 5
million ukrainians could eventually flee
if the fighting continues
this is the fastest growing refugee
crisis in europe since world war ii
david miliband is president and ceo of
the international rescue committee which
oversees relief operations in more than
40 countries affected by the war david
good morning to you
i'm wondering your thoughts as you said
good morning what are your thoughts as
you see this sea of humanity crossing
the borders what stands out to you what
concerns you the most at this time
i think the biggest impression is it
could be me or you these people are
teachers they're journalists they're
charity workers they're business people
they're housewives so refugees who are
fleeing inside ukraine and then crossing
the border are just people what concerns
me most is two things first of all on
the european side of the border people
are obviously safe but there needs to be
proper organization so that the systems
are not overwhelmed i think the european
union has made a very good start in that
inside ukraine i'm desperately fearful
about the people who are trapped in
besieged cities people without water
heating and in some cases healthcare
which is an area where the international
rescue committee specializes so we've
got real fear for people's lives inside
the country and we've got real job to
make sure that people are safe across
the border yeah the situation david does
seem so desperate and heartbreaking tony
decopal who's there as you know told the
story yesterday that a woman told him
of reports of women being raped
by russian soldiers have you heard
stories like that as well
i've certainly read that in the media
we've also got unaccompanied children
and we've got the terrible sight of
civilians trying to get out of besieged
cities being targeted themselves that is
a war crime there's no other way to
describe it david nate burleson here now
the european union is allowing ukrainian
refugees to stay and work for up to
three years what do you make of that
that's good news nate good to have that
question the european union has really
stepped up in the past the 27 countries
of the european union have been divided
on refugee questions today they're
united all 27 countries guaranteeing not
just the right to entry not just the
right to work but the right for every
kid to go to school every adult to
access any social services they need
what organizations like mine do like the
international rescue community we're
there in poland with a team that's going
to branch out across europe we already
have services in greece and in germany
we're really going to provide our
expertise to make sure that the kids are
properly brought into the local
schooling system recognizing the trauma
that they've been through that there's
labor market help for employment for
adults never forgetting that the work we
do across the border into ukraine and
across conflict lines literally keeps
people alive that's why we focus on
health care for example why we focus on
the protection of kids david how does
this treatment compare to refugees from
syria and afghanistan
in the case of the european union we've
got unity now where there was disunity
before we've got welcome now where there
was a very divided response
before in the case of the syrian crisis
it took three months for a million
people to flee syria in the case of
ukraine it's taken a week and we're now
up to one and a half million and and why
do you think that is a lot of people are
starting to say listen when people were
coming here from el salvador honduras
they were they were not
welcome they were not really well they
were not received very well
uh when you talk about syria and
afghanistan too
what do you think is the difference here
well it's simple there's more fear of
incorporating integrating people from
different races and different religions
into national life let's be honest about
it now what we know from the history of
this country the international rescue
committee was founded by albert einstein
we've worked here for 80 years and
around the world for 80 years as well
what we know
is that in the end people fleeing for
their freedom and for their lives
they're desperate to have a second
chance and the countries that they adopt
as their new homes they become patriotic
and productive citizens because of the
chance that it's given them yeah i think
people need to be reminded that you know
we had time and time you look at people
coming from haiti people coming as i
said el salvador honduras they were not
treated this well and i think we all
want the ukrainian people to be helped
everybody agrees with that but there is
enough pain to go around here thank you
so much for your time thank you david
thank you